tonight a local mom needs help tracking
down the owner of a dog she says
attacked her six-year-old child now it
happened earlier this month and ended
with a trip to the emergency room
victoria saha is live at sunset dog park
after speaking to them victoria
yeah this laminated poster was put up by
the family of that little girl doing
everything they can to hopefully make
this dog owner come forward they say a
wolf hybrid dog similar to this one
right here in this poster attacked a
little girl and then they both ran off
but we must warn you the images of the
injuries of that little girl are graphic
six-year-old chloe sunder is slowly
starting to become comfortable around
dogs again this dog come out nowhere
chloe was enjoying a march afternoon at
the dog park with her grandma and aunt
but things turned horrific quickly she
started running towards the obstacle
course on the other side of this park
and
my mom and i started walking towards
there and that's when the dog
tackled her and started thrashing her i
was thinking of
he was like a wolf and
he's really mean and he doesn't like
kids the owner got her dog off of chloe
but when she saw how badly chloe was
hurt she took off i'm thinking maybe
she's putting the dog away so that we
can
exchange information or something like
that a witness was able to briefly note
down a utah license plate number in the
meantime an ambulance took chloe away my
daughter was screaming and crying and
never seen her behave like that before
they clean my owies and then they give
me like
free like needles chloe's mom says
because there were no vaccine records of
the dog chloe had to go through several
rounds of rabies vaccines you're a brave
girl
i'm really tough in the meantime they
have a message for the owner of this dog
you're responsible for your animals
and especially when they're violent and
i can't believe like an adult would just
walk away from a child being injured
like that
chloe's mom wants the dog owner to pay
for the medical bills they have racked
up because because of this chloe will be
going through her last round of rabies
shots this sunday the dog owner is
described to be a woman a blonde woman
in her 40s with a utah license plate and
we did confirm that animal control is
looking into this reporting from sunset
dog port park tonight victoria saha live
local now